vamos con el problema 47 en el problema
47 nos dicen que tenemos dos pisos de un
cierto edificio digamos este de acá y
este de acá y que esos pisos están a
distancia nueve pies entonces de acá
paka paka paka son nueve pies nueve pies
y lo que queremos determinar es cuantos
escalones tiene una escalera que va del
primer piso al segundo piso déjame
dibujar la escalera es algo más o menos
como así
algo así algo así y queremos ver cuantos
escalones tiene vale bueno la
información que nos dan en el enunciado
1 es que cada uno de los escalones mide
tres cuartos de pie de altura entonces
cada escalón tiene tiene tres cuartos de
pie
de altura de altura
altura con esta información podemos
determinar cuántos escalones son porque
si sabemos que esto de aquí es tres
cuartos y estoy aquí déjame tomar otro
color
estos tres cuartos estos tres cuartos
estos tres cuartos entonces tenemos una
ecuación verdad si la cantidad de
escalones es y entonces tres cuartos por
por la cantidad de escalones debe de ser
igual a nueve si y de aquí podemos
determinar cuántos escalones son
simplemente despejando pero no lo vamos
a hacer nada más lo dejamos así y
entonces le ponemos que sí con esta
información se puede determinar cuántos
escalones son y como inciso 2 como
inciso 2 nos dicen que el ancho de cada
escalón es de un pie entonces el ancho
es un pie un pie y por supuesto eso no
tiene nada que ver con el número de
escalones o al menos no con esta
información porque si el ancho es un pie
pues sabemos que esto es un pie esto es
un pie esto es un pie pero eso no está
relacionado con la altura entonces este
de acá nos sirve para determinar cuántos
escalones tenemos y por lo tanto la
respuesta
la respuesta es a vamos al problema 48
problema 48 muy bien aquí nos dicen que
x es distinto de 0 x es distinto de 0
vaya esto simplemente es una forma de
decir que tanto x como ye son distintos
de 0 vale si x es distinto de cero ni xy
ya pueden ser 0 bueno entonces tenemos
esta información y lo que queremos
determinar es si x / i es menor que cero
bueno pues para determinar esto
necesitamos ver si exactamente uno de
estos números es negativo si los dos son
negativos la división queda positiva si
los dos son positivos en la división
queda positiva entonces para que la
división quede negativa
necesitamos que exactamente uno de ellos
tenga signo negativo o bien otra forma
de decirlo es que tengan signos
contrarios van bueno en el inciso 1
nos dicen que x es igual a menos x es
igual a menos yo digo que esta
información es suficiente aquí nos están
diciendo que
y que tienen signos distintos verdad
bueno pues vamos a ver qué sucede de
hecho aquí podemos dividir entre ella de
verdad o sea podemos hacer equis entre
ella y nos queda que eso es igual a
menos 1 y pudimos dividir entre ella
porque ya no es 0 por esta condición de
acá entonces bueno estoy aquí
definitivamente es menor que cero así
que la información del inciso 1 es
suficiente y en el inciso 2 nos dicen
nos dicen que menos x es igual a menos
menos vaya nos están diciendo que menos
x es igual a ye y de manera similar pues
concluimos que x y ya tienen signos
distintos con eso ya podemos terminar o
bien podemos dividir entre menos nos
quedaría que x entre ella es igual a
menos 1 otra vez y eso es menor que cero
va entonces cualquier inciso cualquier
inciso nos permite determinar la
respuesta y entonces la respuesta es b
la respuesta del problema 48 bueno ahora
vamos al problema 49 con otro color un
poco más positivo como el verde entonces
problema 49 nos piden determinar
cuántas personas son directores de tanto
la compañía acá como la compañía r
ok creo que aquí conviene hacer un
diagrama de ven voy a tomar este este
color naranja para pintar aquí un
circulito esto de acá van a ser los
directores de la compañía en la compañía
acá y con otro color voy a pintar a los
directores de la compañía r entonces eso
de ahí son los directores de la compañía
r muy bien y lo que queremos saber es
cuántos son directores de ambas
compañías es decir queremos saber cuánto
cuántas personas están aquí
sale bueno vamos a ver qué incisos de
información tenemos en el enunciado 1
nos dice que hay 17 directores cada vez
que hay una junta de la compañía que
hiere al mismo tiempo y que no falte
nadie va entonces eso lo que nos está
diciendo es que todo esto de acá todo
esto de acá es igual a 17 si nos fijamos
en los que son directores de cada adr o
de ambas en conjunto son 17 vale pero
eso por sí mismo no nos permite
determinar todavía cuánto vale esto de
aquí porque podría estar un poco
desfasado o interpretarse mucho entonces
todavía no lo sabemos vamos a ver qué
dice déjame ponerle que son 17 de acá o
r
y vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 nos dice que la compañía k
tiene 12 directores y la compañía r
tiene ocho directores entonces aquí
todos estos todos los de este circuito
son 12 y todos los de este circuito de
acá son 8 quien ya me falló ya dibuje
más grande este pero pero ni modo
entonces esta información la del inciso
2 déjame ponerle acá o sea que acá es 12
y que eres 8 que eres 8 pues tampoco
sirve por sí misma así solita porque
aquí podría ser 12 y aquí 8 y estar muy
encima 2 entonces podría haber muchos
podría ser que todos los de r son
directores de acá o podrían pasar varias
cosas entonces así solita no sirve y
ésta tampoco pero qué sucede si juntamos
las dos a pues entonces ya suceden cosas
interesantes porque ven estos 17
directores estos 17 directores
el total de los directores es igual a
tomar los directores de cada tomar estos
12 a eso sumarle estos 8 directores de
rr pero pero tenemos que restar esta
parte de aquí los directores dobles
déjame explicar un poco la lógica
tenemos que restar los directores le voy
a poner de de dobles estos de aquí son
dobles porque al sumar estos con estos
estamos contando este cachito dos veces
pero sólo lo queremos contar una vez
vale entonces por ejemplo podemos pensar
en 12 como estos de acá todos los de
cada contando a los de b y luego en 8 -
de como los que sobran aquí en en r vale
bueno pues con esta información ya
podemos determinar el valor de d
simplemente tendríamos que despejarlo lo
voy a hacer lo voy a hacer para para que
te pongas un poquito más feliz cómo le
hacemos aquí lo que podemos hacer es
sumar 12 con 8 y sumar de ambos lados
entonces nos queda que 17 más d es igual
a 20 y ahora restando 17 de ambos lados
nos queda que d es igual a 3
entonces cada una por separado pues no
no responde la pregunta pero si juntamos
las dos obtenemos el valor de de de los
directores dobles entonces la respuesta
sería c la respuesta sería c necesitamos
los dos enunciados para responder la
pregunta muy bien ahora vamos al
problema 50 el problema 50 lo voy a
hacer con color azul problema 50 y aquí
nos pregunta cuál es el dígito de las
décimas a nueces ya lo hicimos el 50 es
si x y ya son positivos entonces tenemos
que xy son positivos entonces a partir
de eso tenemos que determinar que x
entre y bueno determinar si x entre y
hermano mayor que 1 entonces sabemos que
son positivos y hay que determinar si x
entre l es mayor que 1 la información en
el enunciado 1
x es mayor que 1 x es mayor que 1 ok el
producto es mayor que 1 pero creo que de
ahí no se puede deducir esto a ver
déjame reescribirlo para que se vea un
poco más claro multiplicando por allá de
ambos lados nos queda que x es mayor que
ya que pudimos hacer eso porque ya es
positivo y no cambia el signo entonces
necesitamos ver si x es mayor que yo
pero este enunciado de acá no sirve de
nada verdad o sea que el producto sea
mayor que 1 no nos dice como es x con
respecto a y entonces éste de acá no es
suficiente
vamos al 2 en el 2 nos dice que x-men
x-men noche es mayor que 0 jaja pues
aquí si sumamos de ambos lados
concluimos que x es mayor que x es mayor
que yo y eso es justo lo que queremos
bueno si queremos finalmente caerá este
de acá aquí podemos dividir entre que no
se altere el signo porque es positivo y
entonces de aquí podemos deducir que x
entre y es mayor que 1 y por lo tanto el
enunciado 2 si sirve para responder esta
pregunta va y entonces la respuesta
sería b el enunciado 1 no basta
pero el enunciado 2 si vamos a dejarle
hasta aquí le seguimos en el próximo
vídeo